so forgive me who I thought you had
mentioned before that you did some couch
surfing or that when you were first you
know working on the website you stayed
at a friend's house or you did something
yeah no I actually you know I worked at
MTV for three years and I got laid off
with seven hundred other MTV employees
in the same day and after that I went
and I had a project called third rail
which is a murder mystery on a new york
city subway train that is sort of
interactive in transmedia and you know
we had an agent we went out to LA and we
pitched that I spent a lot of time
taking meetings and making script
revisions and what amounted to a lot of
free work you know because people are
always set up at one place and they want
you to make these changes and all sudden
you're realizing that your job is that
to be on conference calls and to be
taking meetings not actually making
movies so my experience coming back to
New York from that was I felt like the
projects that i want to make are risky
now i feel like the people i was meeting
with in hollywood their job was to
mitigate risk you know if they take
risks and they failed and they lose
their job so i wanted to come back and
have something that i owned that i could
hopefully turn into some sort of regular
income stream that would allow me to
make risky projects without having to
say yes to something that i wasn't
interested in doing you know some of our
pitches were oh well you know this
doesn't really fit into our wheelhouse
this is an armed man date but if you if
you want to do something with this you
know comic book property that we own you
know pick up something based on that
that's not what I wanted to do so that's
when I came back and I wanted starting
to film school but you know having been
laid off from my job I didn't have any
income and I knew that starting a
website from scratch was going to take
if it ever took off would take a long
time so the biggest the best thing I
could do was cut out all then my need to
pay rent you know get my bills down as
low as they could possibly be and so
thankfully I had some friends I could
stay with you know so I was
I was in several states I was in Costa
Rica for a while which is great cheaper
than new york and their beaches are
amazing and you know the cost of living
in New York is so high that essentially
I just moved out of my apartment and
then I lived a lot of different places
where any place they had internet access
I could be launching the website I could
be blogging I could be putting up new
posts and researching what to do so that
was great and I think so much of
pursuing a creative career is taking
risks and the risk versus reward of
leaving your day job is a really hard
thing for a lot of people to do and
whenever I get a chance I always
encourage people you know what
especially you know if you're at a time
where you don't have you know kids
depending on you if you're at a time
where the risk of losing your regular
income stream is great it's probably
going to get greater the older you get
so if you believe in yourself and you
want to pursue this artistic pursuit
then there's probably no time like the
present and I think a lot of times it's
hard because you don't know what it's
going to look like or what you're going
to do but there's no really way to find
that out until you give yourself some
space from you know eight hours a day of
doing somebody else is bidding and so
for me it was I have to do this I always
said an MTV that I was going to be my
last day job and so it was me sticking
to my word and you know putting my money
where my mouth is or putting my lack of
money where I don't know that that
analogy gets mixed up but uh you know I
think I had to do it and thankfully it
worked out but you know I imagine what
would have happened if I just did the
safe thing and I just took another day
job and I was a senior designer at MTV
you can make great money doing you know
design make better money doing that then
you know filmmaking for the most part
but so I think I think taking that risk
was the best thing I could have done and
you have to make sacrifices to do that
and for me it was well I'm not going to
have an address for a year but it was
absolutely it was you know it was
it was great what advice can you give to
someone else maybe they're not even a
filmmaker but their quote sleeping on
someone's couch I've been there and
there's a feeling of sort of
powerlessness and you're like am I ever
going to come out of this so what are
some of the tips you can give to other
people that I'm sure you had some pretty
dark night of the soul or maybe you
didn't and it gets scary and but then
you came out and now things are better
so how did you do that how did you kind
of keep those commitments to yourself
because there are probably days when you
could get lost and say you know what I'm
going to find the safe route again you
know I think for for filmmaking and for
creative pursuits the one of the biggest
challenges is when you need permission
and so the whole idea for me getting
away from from from pitching things in
LA during that stretch was you know and
that's how i launched my career was just
making a web series and putting up
online and not requiring somebody else's
permission or approval and I think what
it comes down to is just doing the work
you know we can be here talking about it
and you can do consultancies and you can
write blog posts but ultimately that's
the other reason I track ours is to make
sure that you're doing the work at the
end of the day and you know the more
things you can do that don't require
someone else you know the better as far
as getting your foot in the door making
something putting it out there and you
know hopefully getting attention for it
and moving on to the next step so you
know we're all going to run into
writer's block we're all going to have
those dark nights where you know is what
i'm doing is a terrible and i ever going
to make it at this but but for me the
work ethic and just sitting down there
and focusing on the work is what keeps
me sort of keeps me on track because I
you know I believe in I believe in
failing forward so you're going to learn
as much from something that failed if
not more than you are from something
that was successful so therefore the
only real formula is to just keep doing
the work sounds like you weren't doing
too much ruminating you were just you
were just doing it like not a lot of oh
is this it sounds like you were just
I mean you say the other thing but you
know we're all introspective rumination
can be great as an artist but my big
thing is just no complaining you know no
whining no complaining we all are
struggling with you know massive
obstacles and complaining gets you
nowhere so
you